what movie do you wish you never took
what we smile with you know we were
friends
[Music]
you both do that same thing we have chin
by the way this what your similar and
you guys ever forget get mixed up
between yourselves I think you're the
wrong person never thought you were cold
Cory what does that mean it means that
means that means that I'm strong you're
strong and like muscular and buff
basically means your mom has good taste
we have been told that your way with the
ladies
which way is that III don't know which
way that is however it's this way it's
this way it's the right way like I love
ladies what can I say did it lovely you
know did not love the ladies know where
you will trust me give it two years I
got a cheeky ones how'd it go
kiss I mean mm your look I try and kiss
about ten girls at B otherwise what's
the point
interesting yeah sometimes I do other
things some things I work but mostly I
just kiss girls when I'm old I wanted to
get moved by Bill my mum and dad said it
but I did what do you think okay so that
I your mom might be right if you'd asked
me this two weeks ago I would have said
yeah get more bike but I just had a bit
of an accident so right now I'm hurting
a little bit so I would say your mom is
right don't get a more bike very
dangerous good what's the next question
are you your folks got you a ticket I
did do this guy's actually yes if you
just try try try try it's it's right yes
so you used you use the back of the
floor and your tongue the top of your
tongue and you see things like this and
you
and when you do a Scottish accent you
use your tongue I walk more and your
mouth okay okay okay
is that good Cory you know what maybe do
you wish you never took what oh yeah
what some are with you no we were
friends um what movie do I wish I'd
never took oh I can't
maybe no I can't I'm just gonna I'm just
meet a gamer okay I guess
bye Cory all right Michael
[Applause]